hi dr. Molly I'm having I'm 61 and I'm
having some kind of knee problems on my
right knee I went to the doctor and she
gave me like an x-ray and I catch again
I mean a standard knee you saw it was
inflamed and she did it was like a love
is swollen I want all your products and
I called and I got some kind of leuco
gel plus I don't after like two weeks
but it doesn't seem like it you're going
to take a lot to see is that okay well
first of all how much you weigh about
135 okay and did you get the entire
healthy bone joint
Packer did you just get gluco gel I had
the automatic switch on out I got a good
job of it on that about it all right and
then do you have any history of any
asthma bronchitis no I not allergy
though okay do you have any history of
skin comes eczema dermatitis or
psoriasis I get dry skin in the winter
yes okay and let's see how many children
yes yeah okay do they have any ads or
history of skin problems no anybody have
bowel PUMS celiac disease diverticulitis
appendicitis anything like that
no okay Charmaine are you there I'm here
Romero okay 135 pounds Maria she's just
taking the gluco gel and not getting a
you know something really recognizable
for her knee problem
doctors at x-ray says she's got
inflammation and that kind of stuff
and so gave her some painkillers what do
you think's going on here well she she
may have a gluten intolerance but she
could also take the the cm+
gel caps mm-hmm when I would do that
give her the full healthy bone and joint
pack instead of just the gluco gel
oh I can't Harry pick okay exactly okay
so at 135 pounds
Maria I would have you take one of the
healthy bone and joint packs per month
get an extra bottle of the gluco gel in
an extra bottle of the osteo see
take two ounces of out you they want to
practice one dinnertime take fifteen
gluco gel a day five at breakfast five
at lunch five at dinner and it comes
with CM cream get a little bottle of the
trauma oil put five drops at from all
and every teaspoon of the CM cream
applied to the knee and call us in two
weeks after you get the product so it
started to die it immediately